c'est un don pour le moins hors du
commun qui a reçu la mission bon accueil
de montréal une cargaison de pommes de
terre de l'île du prince édouard d'une
valeur de 15 mille dollars
l'histoire commence quand le généreux
donateur un montréalais la retraite
entend parler des problèmes de
l'industrie de la pomme de terre à l'île
du prince édouard depuis la fin novembre
le gouvernement fédéral interdit
l'exportation vers les états unis après
la découverte de la galerie rue que dans
deux champs un champignon qui défigurent
les pommes de terre mais ne pose aucune
menace pour la santé humaine
l'idée lui est venue au beau milieu de
la nuit racontent ils il allait faire
livrer plusieurs milliers de kilos de
pommes de terre qui se retrouvaient
soudainement sans marcher l'initiative a
depuis inspiré un autre donateur une
nouvelle cargaison aussi imposante
devrait arriver dans les prochains jours
des initiatives réconfortante pour le
représentant des producteurs de l'île du
prince édouard mais il en faudra plus
pour compenser les 120 millions de
dollars que devait y représenter les
exportations aux etats unis cette année
je comprends c'est un enjeu majeur pour
l'industrie la pomme de terre à l'île du
prince édouard et je vous assure que
y'en a qui ont fait fort en ce moment
pour convaincre les américains de
réouvrir le marché dans un premier temps
pour la pomme de terre de table on sait
que ça arrête un peu plus long pour la
pomme de terre de semence il faut faire
plus d' analyse le gouvernement fédéral
a aussi offert une nette de 28 millions
de dollars à l'industrie largement
insuffisant disent les producteurs
devant l'incertitude certains ont décidé
de réorienter temporairement leur
entreprise ici les pommes de terre ont
été remplacés par des boîtes de thé
strates et d'assembler
c'est une bonne idée de cet employé ça
nous donne quelque chose à faire et on
peut aider dans la lutte contre la copie
de
ces les solutions temporaires sont les
bienvenus une véritable sortie de crise
est toujours attendu ici mathieu
papillon radio canada honteux